[Music]
cs go is not a perfect game
by any stretch of the imagination it has
its issues from tick rate
well i shot it in the head 64 tick to
smurfing
this guy's definitely silver bro to
toxicity what the
[ __ ] before i [ __ ] get back in hey [ __ ]
you
being bad yo next time wear a shirt that
fits you fat [ __ ]
but none of these issues stack up to
counter strikes biggest problem
cheating
no seriously no
sir houston so we all know the cheating
sucks and what's even worse is that it
often feels like valve isn't actually
doing anything about it
csgo's lack of an intrusive anti-cheat
system has left a lot of people without
any faith in the existing vac system see
cs go is a really attractive game to
cheat at partly because of its snappy
combat
here's valve at a gdc talk in 2018. the
design is this very satisfying combat
experience where almost any weapon in
the game
can be a one shot uh kill but that does
also sort of fail to disincentivize
cheating the game is also relatively
cheap and easy to run compared to games
like call of duty or battlefield
it's also extremely easy to start up a
new account once one of your old ones
gets banned
so there are a lot of cheaters according
to steamdb
thousands of people get vac manned every
single day and when a wave hits
60 000 people can get hit by the
bandhammer all at once
it's at the point where real great plays
from honest players are being called out
as an example of a cheater who hasn't
been caught
the same pattern he locks on the enemy
then starts doing his weird [ __ ]
shake
this one's right on crisp clean lock
boys
so what does valve do to combat cheating
the current system works on two fronts
the first is vac which looks for
identified and installed cheating
programs and also checks the game files
to make sure nothing's been tampered
with
the other front is overwatch overwatch
lets a selected group watch a reported
player's matches to determine if they're
cheating or not
if enough people vote that the player is
a hacker they get hit by the band hammer
but that existing system is exactly why
cheating is flourished in cs go
so valve began developing vacnet in 2016
after
massive community outrage regarding the
cheating issue only thing the community
was talking about was cheating
uh it was this just deafening
conversation
they silently deployed it at the
beginning of 2017. here we deployed
bacnet and you can see hey we started
getting more convictions that's great
vacnet is a deep learning tool that
works to get as many people into the
overwatch system as possible
vacnet gets a conviction when it submits
a case it convicts
80 to 95 of the time valve also
developed a truss core system
designed to put cheaters in matches with
other cheaters this makes sure that they
play with each other
while clean players play with other
clean players in theory as vac net gets
rolling and more and more cheaters get
banned the game should feel more fair
that's because when those cheaters
return to the game they'll all be
matched up against each other due to
their trust score
but the issue is that the game's top
players have already left valve's
matchmaking system
and while they'll be under vacnet's
watchful eye
it all seems like too little too late
the community has found something of a
solution to the cheating that runs
rampant on valve's official matchmaking
servers
esea and faceit offer third-party
pay-to-play servers with robust
anti-cheap systems
it even has a free version with a lot of
the same benefits neither valve nor esea
or facet want to show their hands and
reveal exactly how their anti-cheats
work
which makes sense if no one knows how
the anti-cheat works then
cheaters will never be able to beat it
what we do know is that both
esea and faceit use intrusive
anti-cheats which check what else is
going on in your computer while you're
playing and
valve uses a much simpler system or like
esca esea can [ __ ] watch porn with me
let me tell you dude i could [ __ ]
pull up a porn thing and some
[ __ ] dev over at esa can watch it
with me having a grand old time
it's very intrusive so they have to let
you know that it's very intrusive they
can tell you exactly what the [ __ ]
you're doing on your comp homie
and that's not the only reason that cs
go players have switched over
faceit and esea boast servers with 128
tick
the rate in which the server refreshes
that's double what valve has and
something the community has wanted for a
long time
there's also a general understanding
that players are going to be less toxic
and more serious on these services
because they're often paying for the
right to play
now that's not always the case toxicity
usually finds a way to seep through
planting
an underwindow under window under window
a new [ __ ] window
god [ __ ] damn it kill him god [ __ ]
terry you guys [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn what are you doing and rank
s and fpl
the top ranks on the servers don't have
a lot of spots to go around
which means only the best players get to
have that experience
but overall third-party software
provides the best experience for
cs go pros to play against other pros
face it and esea even offer payouts for
the top performers in each region at the
end of the season
this system affects real players from
silver to global from rank d minus to s
from bronze to pro league no matter
where you play them if you're an unknown
or less known player
people are more likely to assume you're
cheating than that you actually earned
your rank
and the most recent example of this is
17 year old faceit pro league player
doc doc ripped his way through the face
at ranks and made it to pro league all
without ever using a mic
communication is key in high level cs
and this was pretty unusual
we all robot shut the [ __ ] up
he even streamed his games but with no
camera and again
no mic this gave him an air of mystery
that led to a lot of online speculation
about his
actual skill on the surface doc is a
really talented
player he's even gotten some praise from
top pros
all right skills my friend
yeah my friend if you are not cheating
then you are definitely a good player
congratulations but the overwhelming
voice of people accusing doc of cheating
overshadowed his skill
fellow dutchman chris j reached out to
help doc prove his innocence but he
refused
i asked him if he could come over and
play for my place
and he says he cannot come until he's
18.
it's like whatever if he doesn't want to
prove himself then it's
strange to me but yeah i cannot force
him doc eventually met up with face it
in the netherlands to play under
supervised conditions and prove his
legitimacy so he could join the ranks of
fpl
sure he passed but his reputation is
tarnished if doc ever chooses to pursue
a career in cs go later on in life
those accusations of cheating are going
to haunt him and doc's story is eerily
similar to rox
roth was an up-and-coming player in the
eu fpl and just like doc he had to deal
with plenty of accusations of cheating
early on in his career
he might be cheating actually watch this
[ __ ] man he does like these quick
looks that's so weird bro like why are
you doing that and did it
you did it right after you got the kill
i think it's just one of those things
bro he has an ocd twitch
i don't think he cheats i don't think
they're right about that man you got to
watch
all the other you have to watch all his
streams and see why he's looking there
i think it's just the community picked
apart every aspect of his play to try
and prove that he was cheating
and just like doc robs eventually
traveled to meet with faced employees
and planned her supervised conditions to
prove his legitimacy
he also passed and is now a pro player
playing for mao sports
[Music]
face it might trust her auntie cheat but
after years of dealing with cheaters
running rampant on valve's official
matchmaking services
they don't trust anyone the lack of pros
on matchmaking is a unique
problem to cs go league dota overwatch
all the major esports titles have pros
in the highest echelons of their
matchmaking servers
cs go on the other hand is so broken
that it needs third parties to come in
and clean up the mess
to really have fun in the game and feel
like you're playing anything close to
what the pros play
you tend to need some third-party
service that's not really the case in
league of legends that you've got a
fairly decent ranked system
overwatch likewise not really the case
but valve is off to a good start when it
comes to fixing matchmaking
the new more efficient anti-cheat is
unbelievably important for the longevity
of a competitive multiplayer game
they could change a server and even
tackling smurfing might bring a lot of
players back
but none of that is ever going to matter
to the top level of players
they've left matchmaking behind and as
esea and face it are rapidly improving
there's basically no downside to playing
on them besides some player's monthly
fee
sure the vast majority of cs's casual
audience will reap the benefits of
valve's changes
but the pros are never coming back
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button